vous êtes au centre en ce moment du
débat un mine de rien parce que on a une
crise sanitaire
on a surtout une crise économique qui
est déjà en place et qui nous attend et
tout on nous dit que ça va être vraiment
à un marasme donc on voulait absolument
vous soyez avec nous ce soir
je sais que ce matin déjà vous étiez
dans le nord de la france à béthune pour
annoncer la fermeture de l'usiné
bridgestone
le fabricant japonais a annoncé vouloir
fermer sa seule usine française pour
sauvegarder sa compétitivité en europe 8
163 salariés se retrouve alors sans
emploi bien sûr on pense très très fort
et moi j'avais vu déjà les témoignages
de toutes ces personnes
il ya quelques mois on pensait que le
gouvernement allait pouvoir faire
quelque chose pour cette usine est
finalement à priori c'est cuit
alors merci cyril de parler de ça parce
que je pense que les 8 163 salariés qui
savent aujourd'hui qu'ils vont pas avoir
de solution avec bridgestone
oui avec bridgestone mais nous on est là
pour leur donner une solution sandwich
tonneins alors exactement de cela qu'il
est question
ils ont annoncé il ya deux mois une
décision qui est indigne c'est indigne
c'est vraiment oui je vous le dis c'est
indigne on a essayé de travailler sur un
scénario en leur disant on peut
peut-être faire quelque chose plus petit
plus sa taille raisonnable pour vous ils
nous ont une deuxième fois dit non
d'accord une deuxième fois c'était une
décision indigne donc maintenant on est
au côté des salariés on est merci les
saluer elles vont être les solutions
pour ces 8 163 salariés à qui vraiment
joue dur hein j'ai vu des témoignages
déjà il ya de ça 2 3 mois de gens qui
était en détresse totale
il se tourne vers vous il se tourne vers
le gouvernement vous êtes les seuls à
pouvoir les sauver aujourd'hui quelles
sont les solutions les deux trois pistes
avant courante bien sûr dans le vif du
sujet mais ça rejoint de tuer ce soir ce
qui s'est passé sur cette cuisine quels
sont les deux trois pistes et de trois
solutions que vous auriez pour ces gens
qui va falloir remplacer parce que 1163
salariés il va falloir leur trouver du
travail
est-ce que vous avez déjà des pistes est
ce que vous les avez rassuré ce matin où
évidemment quand on commence à avoir des
pistes parce qu'on n'a pas attendu que
bridgestone ou dit
deuxième fois non pour regarder des
plans alternatifs c'est toujours bon
d'avoir plusieurs cordes à son arc
et en plus le scénario qu'il retenait
supprimer déjà des emplois donc de toute
façon il fallait trouver des solutions
pour les 300 ou 400 personnes sur les
800 kg l'emploi a été remis en cause les
solutions elles sont pas simples mais il
s'agit soit de trouver un repreneur ce
qui est possible et on a déjà quelques
touches soit trouvé des repreneurs c'est
à dire pour des petites unités soit
effectivement d'aller chercher et ça
c'est en plus des solutions pour chacun
des salariés vous avez des salariés
qu'ils nous disent mais moi j'ai un
projet à l'extérieur de l'usiné
moi j'aimerais bien reprendre une
formation et ça on peut les accompagner
et on va le faire avec la région avec le
président d'agglomération parce que 815
63 emplois dans ce coin là c'est plus
complexe pour béthune c'est pas ridicule
pour la région donc tout le monde est
quand même très alignés pour trouver des
solutions et nous c'est notre intérêt
que ces gens-là retrouve des emplois
parce que derrière c'est le petit café
c'est le boulanger s'est même l'école je
suis père il faudrait pas traité juste
le problème avant la crise c'est à dire
mieux former ses employés les préparer à
une reconversion
parce qu on est tout le temps dans même
schéma on cherche dans la panique
une solution un repreneur on sait que
neuf fois sur dix en fait c'est
l'entreprise qui a la main et qui dit
non et tous ces gens se retrouvent sur
le carreau dans une détresse
incroyable il y avait des vraiment des
témoignages qui vous faisait monter les
larmes aux yeux parce que les gens
disent j'ai 50 ans ma vie est foutue
quoi ça est-ce que c'est pas avant qu'il
faut intervenir
là vous intervenez comme un pompier est
ce qu'il vaut mieux pas faire en sorte
que le feu ne se déclare sont
complètement d'accord avec vous ce titre
une usine qui a été laissé à l'abandon
depuis une dizaine d'années
effectivement c'est facile ensuite
constater qu'elle est plus au niveau de
l' usine polonaise ou de l' usine
hongroise est ce qui est en plus très
injuste c'est que les gens dans cette
usine mais les les salariés de cette
usine les opérateurs qui sont là depuis
20 ans depuis 30 ans qu'ont certains
d'entre eux c'est eux c'est eux qui sont
allés fort mais les polonais les
hongrois
c'est pas du cru qu'ils ont créé leurs
concurrents donc aujourd'hui comment on
fait vous avez raison faut former les
gens c'est exactement pour ça qu'on met
le paquet sur ça mais on va pas
remplacer les les entreprises donc il
faut qu'on accompagne ces personnes pour
s'assurer qu'à aucun moment laisse
tomber des usines andry